How to preprocess pairs of sentences? We have
seen how to tokenize single sentences and batch
them together in the "Batching inputs together"
video. If this code look unfamiliar to you,
be sure to check that video again! Here we will
focus on tasks that classify pairs of sentences.
For instance, we may want to classify whether two
texts are paraphrases or not. Here is an example
taken from the Quora Question Pairs dataset,
which focuses on identifying duplicate questions.
In the first pair, the two
questions are duplicates;
in the second, they are not. Another pair
classification problem is when we want to know
if two sentences are logically related or not (a
problem called Natural Language Inference or NLI).
In this example taken from the MultiNLI dataset,
we have a pair of sentences for each possible
label: contradiction, neutral or entailment
(which is a fancy way of saying the first sentence
implies the second). So classifying pairs of
sentences is a problem worth studying. In fact,
in the GLUE benchmark (which is an academic
benchmark for text classification),
8 of the 10 datasets are focused
on tasks using pairs of sentences.
That's why models like BERT are often
pretrained with a dual objective:
on top of the language modeling objective, they
often have an objective related to sentence pairs.
For instance, during pretraining, BERT is shown
pairs of sentences and must predict both the
value of randomly masked tokens and whether
the second sentence follows from the first.
Fortunately, the tokenizer from the
Transformers library has a nice API
to deal with pairs of sentences: you just have
to pass them as two arguments to the tokenizer.
On top of the input IDs and the attention
mask we studied already, it returns a new
field called token type IDs, which tells the
model which tokens belong to the first sentence
and which ones belong to the second sentence.
Zooming in a little bit, here are the input IDs,
aligned with the tokens they correspond to, their
respective token type ID and attention mask.
We can see the tokenizer also added special
tokens so we have a CLS token, the tokens
from the first sentence, a SEP token, the tokens
from the second sentence, and a final SEP token.
If we have several pairs of sentences, we can
tokenize them together by passing the list of
first sentences, then the list of second sentences
and all the keyword arguments we studied already,
like padding=True. Zooming in at the result,
we can see how the tokenizer added padding
to the second pair of sentences, to
make the two outputs the same length,
and properly dealt with token type IDS
and attention masks for the two sentences.
This is then all ready to pass through our model!